all right so one more sort of Carrie
Lake story but it's also a Tulsi gabbard
story I don't know that I have to rehash
the entire story but Tulsi gabbard is a
former democratic congresswoman she ran
for president back in 2020 for the
Democratic primary and at the time I
told you guys this is not really a
leftist this is a grifter this is not an
interesting candidate she's not bringing
interesting ideas she's just bamboozling
people and many in my audience
understood that some did not and they
said Tulsi is the last real liberal
she's truly the anti-war candidate she's
truly this that the other thing okay
obviously untrue cut to last week Tulsi
says I'm no longer a Democrat and in Her
speech leaving the Democratic party she
lists a whole bunch of different
conspiracy theories anti-white racism
wokism
um an elitist cabal that's in control it
is like it's almost like Q Anon stuff
but she's an independent now she's a
Centrist and she's take blah blah blah
okay who's she campaigning for last
night Kerry Lake
Carrie like Tulsi gabbard widely
promoted as showing up in support of
Kerry Lake one of the most extreme
candidates running in 2022 who has a
chance to win I will tell you a little
bit about that in a moment but here are
Tulsi and Carrie throwing bouquets at
each other
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you know what's amazing the young
Republicans are not just the future they
are the Republican Party the new
Republic
of Austin yeah
um Tulsi gabbard who wants us to believe
that she is no longer part of the
democratic party but she's still a
Centrist she still holds many
Progressive or at least left-leaning
values and she sees the good of both
sides and all this stuff one of her
first acts as an independent having left
defiantly and because of her principles
and values left the Democratic party one
of her first acts is to show up in
support of Carrie Lake who led anti-mask
rallies anti-mask masks guys told a
group of Republican retirees she was
preemptively prophylactically taking
hydroxychloroquine to avoid getting
coveted 19. that's something Carrie Lake
said to people
um Carrie Lake said that if she becomes
Governor she will work to have
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin
produced in Arizona to make it easier to
get people those like life-saving Cova
drugs which of course don't do anything
to help when you have coveted as
demonstrated by actual medical trials
she accused Joe Biden and Democrats of
having a quote demonic agenda she's
doing the demonic stuff and Tulsi goes
now that I'm a clear thinking
independent I'm going to go and support
Carrie Lake uh Carey Lake expressed
support for Banning both Surgical and
medication abortions outright in Arizona
and of course Kerry Lake for nearly two
years has been a leading voice
arguing
that Trump won the 2020 election when he
very clearly and obviously lost
Kerry lake is a disgusting ideologue an
extremist reactionary
and now that Tulsi gabbard is seeing the
world more clearly because she's no
longer part of the Democratic Party
she chooses to go and say Here's who I'm
supporting Carrie Lake
absolutely disgusting and I've been
hearing from dozens of our viewers over
the last week since Tulsi bailed on the
Democratic Party
dozens of our viewers saying David I
fell for it I fell for it and I feel so
stupid now
it was so obvious guys Tulsi gabbard was
not what she claimed to be and now she's
campaigning for Kerry Lake we'll have
these clips by the way that I played on
our Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show
our sponsor magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal that tastes amazing but without
the sugar carbs and the crazy
ingredients magic spoon has taken your
favorite childhood cereals and
brilliantly transformed them into
something you can feel good about eating
because each serving has zero grams of
sugar under five net carbs and is packed
with 13 grams of protein so it'll work
for keto and low carb but it's really
perfect for anyone who wants the
occasional sweet crunchy treat without
the sugar their portfolio of eight plus
unique delicious flavors allow you to
never get bored my favorite is maple
waffle but they've got the classics like
cocoa fruity frosted also cinnamon roll
blueberry muffin our entire team has
been eating magic spoon for years we
love it but if you don't they send you
all your money back it's really easy
magic spoon has been supporting the
David Pacman show for a long time they
always give my audience five dollars off
when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below